l'allemagne le coeur économique de
l'europe est déchiré
le gaz russe qui lui permet en grande
partie de fonctionner sur at-il coupé
doit-on cessé d'en importer
en banlieue de hambourg l'entreprise
familiale de arnold mergele transforme
des produits chimiques depuis 120 ans
l'un de ces mélanges est utilisé sur les
voitures pour éviter la corrosion on le
retrouve dans 70% des véhicules sur le
marché européen
pour obtenir ces produits ces machines
créer de la vapeur à environ 280 degrés
celsius le tout est alimenté par du gaz
naturel provenant de russie annie guay
pour se défaire de cette dépendance
arnold merguez mise sur l'hydrogène et
la transition prendra encore quelques
années
si le gaz est si important dans cette
usine comme dans des milliers d'autres à
travers le pays c'est entre autres en
raison des choix qui a pris l'allemagne
quant à ces sources d'énergie
gas
company
une dépendance causés par des choix
économiques mais qui s'explique aussi
par des décisions politiques et
diplomatiques les allemands sont devenus
extrêmement ont choisi de devenir
dépendants du gaz russe dans l'espoir
que cette interdépendance
germano-russe permettent un changement
de la politique étrangère de la russie
une approche plus pacifique et
coopératrices est évidemment depuis le
24 février et l'agression militaire de
vladimir poutine contre la nation
ukrainienne on voit clairement que cette
politique allemande à échouer
une approche défendu pendant près de
quinze ans par la chancelière angela
merkel mais c'est d'abord à son
prédécesseur gerhard schröder que l'on
doit cette stratégie ce politicien est
critiqué pour sa proximité avec moscou
si j'ai encore aujourd'hui au conseil
d'administration d'entreprises
énergétiques russes donc même quand
mario paul est en train de mourir sous
les bombes sous les bombes le devenir
poutine quart d'heure continue à toucher
ses jetons de présence que j'imagine
fort généreux et du coup être rémunérés
par des entreprises d'état et des
entreprises pétro gazière russe pour ses
bons et loyaux services
dès le début de la guerre en ukraine un
changement d'approché majeures a été
décrétée
le nouveau chancelier olaf scholz
annoncé la suspension de la
certification du gazoduc north stream 2
une immense projet qui devait grandement
augmenter la part de gaz russe acheminés
vers l'allemagne
le gaz russe continue néanmoins d'entrer
chaque jour sur le territoire allemand
55 % l'an dernier la ressource
représente maintenant en 35 % des
importations du pays
avant de s'en affranchir entièrement il
faudra être patient berlin évoque la mi
2024 pour y arriver la solution repose
en partie ici le long du fleuve elbe
dans l'ouest du pays le port de bronze
moteur est l'un des endroits
sélectionnés pour accueillir du gaz
naturel liquéfié
le but remplacer le produit venu de
russie par du gaz norvégien au qatari
c'était lui explique que cela fait des
années qu'ils militent pour ce projet
qui profitera à la région et aidera
l'allemagne à avoir accès à des sources
d'énergie diversifiées
or le gouvernement fédéral ne s'est
jamais montrée intéressée elle financée
il aura fallu la guerre pour que le
processus s'accélère enfin port gazier
devrait voir le jour d'ici deux ans dès
l'an prochain des terminaux flottant
devrait être installé pour commencer
l'approvisionnement
a plus que l'hybride
écrit le maire de laver leur est aussi
préféré que le projet soit autorisée
avant en temps de paix plutôt que d'être
précipité à cause de la guerre mais il
se réjouit qu'enfin il y ait un début de
solution à la crise énergétique qui mine
le pays appelé marie personnes
dans les conversations le gaz et surtout
son prix s'impose rapidement c'est le
cas dans ce restaurant
à l'est selon la
cuisinière le chauffage le gaz est à la
base de tout dans cet établissement pour
le propriétaire le constat est clair
l'énergie venus de russie s'est finie
tel rossland probants
mais avec les risques de récession
combien coûtera cette décision voilà la
grande question
s'il s'oppose à un embargo immédiat
l'industriel arnold mergele croit
néanmoins que l'allemagne finira par
franchir le pas
en plus de l'importation de gaz naturel
liquéfié d'ici 10 ans berlin prévoit
déjà doublé la part de solaire et
d'éolien dans sa production
d'électricité
aujourd'hui grandement critiqué pour sa
dépendance à la russie l'allemagne
pourrait bien tirer des leçons de la
tempête qui souffle sur le pays